- All right.
We are back and I'm here
with Abigail and Emily
of Barlow & Bear.
They're the creators of the
unofficial "Bridgerton Musical".
We didn't talk about that
last time, but Barlow & Bear,
I don't remember talking about
that's the coolest name ever,
Barlow & Bear.
- It just worked.
- Yeah.
- It works well.
I would, yes.
You could see it on everything,
merch, and everything.
Next week, Broadway
welcomes its newest star,
When Talia Suskauer takes center stage
as Elphaba in "Wicked".
It's a role made famous by Idina Menzel.
Talia was so stoked when
she first found out,
she decided to surprise her vocal coach
with the news in a video that's
since gone viral and you'll see why,
take a look.
- [Talia] I'm gonna be
Elphaba on Broadway.
- Whoa, whoa.
Whoa, golly
I told you when you were 12.
- I know you did.
- Oh my God.
I'm so happy for you.
- Thank you.
You're gonna have to come to New York.
- Oh, I will now, for sure.
- I love that.
After that video, we had to bring them on.
Please welcome Talia Suskauer,
and her vocal coach, Craig Wick.
Now give it up!
(audience cheering)
- I love that video,
meet the girls.
- I'm huge fans of you all.
- Congratulations.
- We'll be seeing you.
- On Broadway!
- It's a very musical show thus far.
Yes. I love this.
Well, congrats on the new role.
It's kind of a new role.
I mean, you've been in
the role for a while,
but it's now you're on
Broadway in the role.
- Yes.
Yeah, which is wild.
I mean, this is really a
dream come true for me.
I saw the show when I was nine,
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- on Broadway.
That's how long the show's been around.
I was always into musical theater,
and always very theatrically inclined,
and started taking voice
lessons with this guy here,
Craig Wick.
- Way to go Craig!
- Way to go, hey!
(audience cheering)
- And when I was like 12 years old,
we started singing the
music from "Wicked",
and he told me you're gonna do this role
on Broadway someday.
- Oh wow.
- And I kind of held
that dream in my heart,
and with a lot of hard work,
went to college musical theater,
and started playing the role
on the national tour of "Wicked",
summer of 2019.
And obviously we had a
pandemic in between, but
- Some things happened.
- Some things happened and
- Life shut down
- Life shut down, and yeah.
- So you were surprised,
but you kind of weren't,
cuz you kind of knew she
was gonna always do this.
- Well, Talia came to
me like most young girls
they they're pressing the voice
to produce these belt sounds
and we had to take the pressure off.
Get her to develop flow foundation,
and what happened was
she had this phenomenal operatic voice,
which most people don't understand.
She could be an operatic star at The Met.
- Those are the best singers
then that are able to do that.
- Yeah, then once you
stabilize that larynx,
then you just adjust
the different harmonics.
So she took two, it belt
her tunes to the second,
third and fourth harmonic.
So she figured that out,
and she was brilliant.
And we did a define gravity
one day in the studio
and I just looked at her, my jaw dropped.
I said you were going to do
this on Broadway, but I knew it.
I knew, I knew it.
I've told the story to many
people, thousands of times.
And I knew it.
She knew it, you know?
- I love that.
Well y'all have seen "Wicked", obviously.
- Oh my yeah.
- Well, I don't know you
haven't seen "Bridgerton", yet.
(all laughing)
- Maybe you're a little
late to that game, too.
- Oh, don't come for us.
- Barlow & Bear,
I see you down there.
I don't mean, that was amazing
That was well, I am not the only one
who's totally moved by Talia's video.
There's someone backstage who
wants to wish her good luck
on her Broadway debut.
So will that person come out?
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Oh my God.
- You're beautiful.
- You're such a good teacher.
- I just missed you at the
Gershwin by like a week,
couple weeks.
- I'll come back, I'll come back.
- Please.
- I know I brought all
those smelly, prepubescent
boys to the show.
And you missed that.
I'm so happy for you.
And the advice that I would give or
that Kelly might give
as well is make sure you
wear the black opaque tights underneath.
- You got it.
- Just in case you're
drinking a lot of water,
and someone makes you
laugh and you have a,
and you pee in your pants.
It sops it up really good.
And then you can just go
right out there and fly.
- Can I just say the amount of times
I have like sung to you in my car?
It's just like, it's crazy.
- I'm just gonna hang out with you.
I love that her whole
body turned towards you,
like a whole, no stay turned, stay turned,
you have your moment, ma'am.
You stay turned,
I'm just gonna come join you.
Cuz Chris is like,
you're out there on an island.
- I was like, no, I gotta say,
I gotta ask her.
Do you remember your first time?
Like when you heard you got the role.
- Oh my God, yeah.
- And you didn't actually know
the gravity haha, to find,
yeah, I didn't even mean to do it.
You didn't actually even know
that you keep your posture
to face that way.
No, I was messing with you.
I was messing with you.
No, do you remember that moment, you know?
Cause you didn't know
how big it was gonna be.
You didn't know what was going on.
- Oh my God,
I yeah, no, it was incredible.
We didn't know what it was going to be.
It was different.
But I just remember auditioning,
and working on it with
my ex-husband actually,
who was my best friend and I
was learning to find gravity,
and I just knew, I said, this is something
it just made me wanna cry
when I was practicing at home.
And then when I got it, I just
I felt like, yeah, it was
you just know when you're
gonna be a part of something.
You don't know how big it it's gonna be
or whatever, but yeah.
I'm so just glad that you're here,
and you're going to extend,
what am I trying to say?
- You know, you know what,
it's such a big role, right?
Do you ever, do you feel pressure?
There's been some Elphaba's, right?
Do you ever feel that pressure
or you know what you should,
- Do you feel like you have
huge footsteps to fill?
- Well, what I actually
feel is the strength
of all of the women that
have played the part for me.
- Optimism, I like you.
- It's true, cause I
get asked a lot, like,
you know people are coming to the theater,
they're expecting you know,
to hear the cast album,
and I'm never gonna be this
incredible person right here
but I can be me and I
walk in the footsteps
of all these incredible women
that have played this part
and bring their unique strength to this.
It's just incredible, so yeah.
- Yeah. Ah, empty chairs, empty table.
See, it's another big song for that one.
So "Wicked" is playing
at the Gershwin Theater,
in New York City.
If you haven't seen it yet, shame on you
you should go see it.
It is so amazing.
You can see Talia Suskauer
in the role of Elphaba, starting May 24.